[Music]
a certified avalanche dog like tally can
do the work of about 30 rescuers in the
same amount of time
their sense of smell is 10 times greater
than ours and if someone's buried in the
snow or not even buried but just lost in
the woods the dog can smell their scent
coming up through the snowpack and tell
me where to start digging to find that
person
we are the first responders and a lot of
times if things go
well into our training we can facilitate
that rescue without putting anybody else
in harm's way and be done quickly and
efficiently and all go home safely we
got to find somebody i know you want to
find somebody okay let's go
search my name is hunter mortensen i'm
an avalanche technician here at
breckenridge ski resort with my ski
patrol partner tally and we've been
working here for eight years together
we're really fortunate here at
breckenridge we have six avalanche
rescue dogs on staff today tally's
hearing with her co-workers and friends
is boudreaux the golden retriever and a
up another mountain purebred mutt
the years of the big saint bernard and
swiss mountain dog with the barrel under
their neck those dogs are built for the
mountains they're sturdy they're hardy
they can do it but what we're finding is
they don't travel well in the snow and
they're not as fast moving across the
snow and avalanche rescues all a matter
of time so we're looking these days for
dogs that are a little bit on the
smaller side a little more nimble and a
little more quick
so the training we start him
six to nine months old and a lot of it
is just basic obedience and then we
start building from the obedience into
actual hide-and-go-seek type games and
then we build up from there into big
snow caves where we'll bury a person
almost six feet deep if we have enough
snow and then the dog will start
searching having to find where that
scent is coming up to play the game and
all they're really looking for is that
person who they think has their toy oh
that sounds good girl
it's about two full years of training to
take your last certification test for an
avalanche rescue dog and handler so i'm
certified to work with tally
ready
my whole last eight years of my career
have been spent with her
every day all day when we have to do our
thing we're really dependent on each
other
and i couldn't do what i do without her
and so it's an amazing partnership and
i'm really honored and proud to be a
part of this program and work with a dog
like her
[Music]
farm is a farm in south africa
[Applause]
in a special farm because i use ducks
instead of pesticides to work in vanilla
[Applause]
pesticide is dangerous for the
environment
the ducks are not dangerous
they are natural pest controllers on the
farm
the snails will ruin the wine stick
shelf and the ducks prevent that from
happening by eating the snails
the first thing i do is i go into the
garage and that is where we breed our
ducks
[Music]
after that i will start feeding the
ducks
then at quarter to 10 in front of the
main house we do something like a duck
parade all our ducks is marching in one
straight line
then we send them off to go and work in
the wrong yards
and they will do 50 square meters per
day
there is 1 1071 ducks in the working
group allowed but we still have some
breeding ducks and those ducks are about
300 attacks
the favorite is the crested duck is a
duck with a type of hairstyle like a
pompom on top with it so i named him
javos
[Music]
the ducks are so
close to me
they see me as they mummy because i take
care of them each day and i communicate
with them
that is for me unique
the ducks are not only just ducks
but they are there for a reason
[Music]
blakely has the most difficult job at
cincinnati zoo he has to play with
babies all the time
[Music]
he's never shown any aggression or
snapped if he gets upset kind of like
any mom would he just leaves the room
you are so cute
my name is don strasser and we're at the
cincinnati zoo and botanical gardens
blakely is a five-year-old australian
shepherd we got him from a rescue and i
use him in a nursery as a nanny or a
companion dog this is about you and
you're taking a nap blakely's here for
the main purpose of teaching the babies
the correct animal cues as they grow up
so when they are introduced back to
their own kind they know what
appropriate behavior is he teaches them
how to play how to interact
i can tell them no don't bite me but i'm
not an animal and i don't give the same
cues that he can
so we make a great team
[Music]
smile for this camera
blakely has worked with cheetahs
ocelots
a talking
battered foxes a warthog
wallabies
to name a few he's working with four
baby cheetahs right now
it's been a long seven weeks for him
with these little cheetah cubs and he's
i think tired because he's on alert for
24 hours a day if they start making too
much noise he'll come and get us like
something's not right something's not
right
he's kind of like a second set of eyes
for us too a lot of times they still
recognize each other like dale the talk
and he raised when they see each other
he'll they'll still run up up front and
grunt at him and he'll kind of jump up
on the wall and it's kind of like hey
how you doing
he's beautiful thank you
yeah well i i like to think i have an
office but i'm pretty sure it's his
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
in the peak of summer in italy
when the beaches and lakes are full of
swimmers
the lifeguards keeping everyone safe
bring in some much-needed assistance
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
has found that dogs make ideal lifeguard
partners they remain calm under pressure
and instinctively choose the safest path
through the water currents back to shore
once in the water they're able to keep
afloat both the rescuer and the person
in need
is
[Music]
[Music]
to keep up with these numbers the school
has over 350 certified rescue dogs
and each year takes in new recruits
[Music]
after about 18 months of training they
learn how to jump from speeding boats
and helicopters safely
among other rescue techniques
[Music]
italy is the only country in the world
that recognizes these certified canines
as actual lifeguards but the value of
this is catching on so the school is
starting to expand abroad
humanoid
[Music]
you